kl action analyse avec gérard araud que
vous connaissez bien ancien ambassadeur
de france aux états unis messieurs a
robot soir bonsoir vous avez écrit dans
un texte en fin de semaine ça peut
sembler contre intuitif mais pour forcer
des cessez le feu une vraie négociation
il faut armer encore plus l'ukraine
explique henno
oui parce que vous savez dans un conflit
on arrive on vient là cadre de
négociations parce que soit en est le
vainqueur soit on est le vaincu soit on
se rend compte qu'on ne peut pas
l'emporter or pour le moment tout s'ils
pensent qu'il peut l'emporter poutine
n'ira pas à la table de négociations
sauf si l'ukraine capitule donc pour
l'amener à la table de négociation la
seule l'alternative c'est de donner des
armes aux ukrainiens de quelle sorte
qu'il soit capable de résister aux
russes et qu'à un certain moment foutent
ils me disent ça me coûte trop cher il
vaut mieux il vaut mieux que je négocie
on vient d'entendre avant de vous allez
vous voir monsieur blinken qui dit on
est en train de voir il ya des appareils
le problème c'est que les pilotes
ukrainiens ne peuvent pas conduire tous
les avions alors comment vous voyez la
suite des choses pour armer l'ukraine
sans entrer directement avec les forces
de l'otan avec et c'est donc elle est où
la limette
alors moi ce que je comprends c'est que
la pologne est peut-être également
d'ailleurs la roumanie et d'autres pays
des anciens pays de l'est possède encore
des mig et notamment des mig-29 qu'ils
ont modernisé et qui ont été modernisées
d'ailleurs avec du matériel américain
est donc ce que les polonais disent aux
américains s'est autorisé nous à les
transférer aux ukrainiens mais également
prométhée nous de les remplacer par des
avions de combat parce que si nous les
polonais nounou des sessions de nos
avions évidemment nous ou nous semblons
nous nous sentirons vulnérables donc je
crois que l'idée c'est la fourniture aux
pilotes ukrainiens qui devrait savoir
les utiliser des mig-29 que possède
encore la pologne parce qu'évidemment on
ne peut pas leur donner des pilotes
polonais ou des pilotes de pays membres
de l'otan
non ce serait en ce serait un acte de
guerre ça voudrait dire que des polonais
voir des américains des français à
battre ou se bat avec des avions russes
ce serait un acte de guerre contre le
pays la pologne les etats-unis la france
et la russie et cela depuis le début
nous l'avons dit nous ne voulons pas y
arriver est ce qu'on peut en donnant des
avions après tant d avion polonais
arrivés aux mêmes au même but c'est à
dire une sorte de zone d'exclusion
aérienne
ou non la raison d'exclusion aérienne
c'est si vous savez avec des moyens à la
fois anti aériens et aériens interdire à
l'aviation ennemie de de se déployer
dans cet espace là ce serait simplement
de donner les moyens aux ukrainiens de
se battre d'égal à égal avec l'aviation
avec l'aviation l'aviation russe donc
apparemment vous avez raison comme vous
l'avez dit c'est un domaine l'aviation
où les rues sont mieux supériorité une
grande supériorité ce serait une manière
de rétablir ce rapport de force toujours
dans cette logique d'amener les russes à
la conclusion qu'ils ne parviendront pas
à leurs fins par des moyens militaires
et qu'il dort d'où doivent donc négocier
déjà qu'on conçoit la 12e journée qu'est
ce que ça vous dit sûr quand même la
résistance ukrainienne est donc
peut-être cette envie qui va se
développer chez boots and aller négocier
il ne veut pas non plus à l'aise en
ukraine en image n on vous savez excusez
moi mais douze jours de guerre ce n'est
rien ce n'est rien nous allons nous
entrons dans une guerre qui va durer des
semaines et peut-être des mois c'est une
vraie guerre nous avons oublié nous les
occidentaux est peut-être encore vous
plus les canadiens vivent entre
géographie vous avons oublié ce que
c'était une vraie guerre une vraie
guerre c'est sale c'est dur et ça
détruit eh bien nous allons nous sommes
au moment où poutine pense qu'il peut
gagner il est évident que s'il devait
négocier faire des concessions cela
paraît aujourd'hui comme un échec il n'a
pas atteint ce moment là il va donc au
contraire redoublé de violence pour
essayer de briser la résistance des
ukrainiens dans les semaines qui
viennent
et les corridors humanitaires on sait on
a vu un puissant en fin de semaine
encore l'échec des pourparlers est-ce
que là il peut y avoir des progrès ce
que les civelles on peut mieux les
protéger
là je viens de lire juste avant votre
émission je viens de lire que le
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
a annoncé que la russie était prête à
ouvrir des couloirs humanitaires
à partir de septembre deux villes
notamment kharkov marioupol et kiev là
c'est évidemment que les russes ont un
intérêt à ce que le nombre des victimes
des victimes civiles soient réduits mais
sur le terrain c'est très difficile en
général et on a en particulier
l'impression que les russes ne contrôle
pas bien leurs troupes que les
communications tactiques n'est ce pas
entre les soldats sur frau et lang le
commandement de sont pas très bonnes
donc ils ont 20 ans j'espère que ça
marchera ça permettra sans doute à un
certain nombre de civils de se tirer de
ces villes assiégées mais nous ne
faisons pas d'illusions ce n'est pas la
solution à tous les problèmes il y aura
il y aura évidemment des incidents bon
pour résumé gérard araud vous êtes pour
qu'il y ait une réelle négociation il
doit avoir un rapport de force change et
donc un afflux d'armes et de matériel
militaire du côté de l'ukraine si on
veut la paix
oui c'est ça qui est parent inquiet
c'est ça qui est paradoxal et en
particulier par rapport à nos je dirais
à nos à nos consciences d'occidentaux
nous avons la chance incroyable d'avoir
connu la paix depuis 1945 75 ans de paix
moi je quand je sujet jacques quand
j'étais enfant mes parents mes grands
parents me parler des deux guerres
mondiales nous avons eu trois
générations sans guerre nous ne pouvons
pas comprendre cela mais voilà c'est une
guerre c'est une vraie guerre et pour
obliger pour amener l'ennemi car c'est
un ennemi la russie à la négociation il
faut qu'elles se sentent obligés
à dire il faut qu'elle pense qu'elle ne
peut pas l'emporter un prix acceptable
pour elle il y aura donc devant nous je
le crains beaucoup de destructions de
victimes civiles ce sera un long conflit
gérard a remercié nous avoir parlé merci
on se reparle je vous en prie au revoir